- [David] Hello, Readers!
Today we are going to talk
about making connections.
So I don't mean to brag, but I
have at least one friend.
(I'm kind of a big deal.)
I have friends at work, friends
from the school I attended,
friends in my apartment
building and my neighborhood,
friends from places I used to live.
Each friend is connected
to me in some way.
May be we met in an
elevator or on the train,
or at the community garden.
In some cases, I introduced my friends
and now they're friends with each other
and even hang out without me.
Each friend is connected to me
or to each other in a different way
and for a different reason.
And just in a way the people
can be friends with each other
ideas can be friends with each other too.
Understanding how ideas
that tends to connect
with each other and the topic of text
will help me understand what I'm reading.
Good readers make connections
between ideas in the text.
When I look at a passage, I ask myself
what do all these
sentences have in common.
How are they connected?
Let's explain with a brief
passage about building ships.
Long ago, shipbuilders used iron nails
and bolts because iron was easy to find.
They soon learned the disadvantages
of using this metal on a boat!
Iron quickly rusts and decays,
especially near the salty ocean.
They switched to using
brass, which lasts longer.
I wanna use this paragraph
to describe three common ways
authors show connections.
Comparison, cause-and-effect and sequence.
Comparison; what's the same or
different between two ideas?
So what's similar between
brass and iron is one example.
We can say okay, both of these are metals
and both were used in shipbuilding.
Now what's different between them?
Well, iron rusts quickly in the ocean
and it does so faster than brass.
Brass lasts longer.
Now let's talk about cause and effect.
How does one event or idea
cause another event or idea.
Well what happens when you put a ship
with iron bolts into salt
water? It rusts and decays.
The ocean causes the
iron to corrode and rust.
So what did shipbuilders do as a result,
they switch to using brass.
And finally sequence.
What order did things happen in?
Now the paragraph begins with long ago
and talks about iron before
it talks about brass.
It then describes how
shipbuilders switched to brass.
So iron came first in the sequence.
So when I read this
passage on shipbuilding
even though it is very short,
I'm able to make a lot of
connections between ideas.
Doing this deepened my understanding
and helps me to become a better reader.
Now not every sentence
or idea is connected
to every other sentence or idea.
Just like not every single
one of my friends is friends
with all of my other friends.
And that's okay too.
Our goal is to think about
how those sentences connect
to the topic overall.
Think about the big picture.
Understanding the
connections between sentences
is one of many ways you can strengthen
your skills as a reader.
You can learn anything.
Dave it out!